i love halloween i've always liked
halloween i like it because
it's about simulated
horror and i think simulated horror
is a nice way to get away from actual
horror what actual horror happens
from uh november 1st
all the way to october 30th and then one
day everyone goes let's pretend
that we're scared let's find things to
scare us
boo like haunted houses and
scary movies but the other 364 days are
filled with very real
verifiable accounts of nightmarish
behavior
that by the very grace of god and sheer
luck you don't find yourself embroiled
in
it's hard to enjoy movies like hostile
because i i used to think they were fake
i can't enjoy them anymore as much
because i guarantee you
there is a place in bratislava where you
can take a drill
and go through some taurus eye and if
there isn't
there should be because if there's not
you're leaving a lot of money on the
goddamn table
you can't enjoy texas chainsaw massacre
anymore
why because now you don't see
leatherface as someone scary
you see him as somebody that runs for
the senate
how can you enjoy horror film it's
better any
jason freddie crew these people are all
better than the people who run the
country
they've all done less killing
they've all done less killing than our
leaders how do you enjoy a horror movie
house of a thousand corpses how nice it
would be if there were only a thousand
corpses
do you know how many of these third
world countries would go you only killed
a thousand of us
they'd be dancing in the street with
american flags on right now
a thousand corpses is tuesday morning
before you have [ __ ] lunch how can
you enjoy a horror movie now it's hard
it's difficult when you know the actual
[ __ ] that goes on
if leatherface was around today he'd be
running
a major facebook q a on account that
just got
shut down and he'd come out and say they
shouldn't have shut me down and i kind
of agree with leatherface i think he's
got crazy ideas but i agree with
leatherface
and then he'd mount a campaign for you
know local congress or something
what are your favorite scary movies
favorite
halloween movies favorite halloween
movie
uh off the top of my head hocus pocus
because i watched it when i was a kid
very gay hocus pocus now ben is a wife
and i i hope she's not in therapy
in years from now hocus pocus is a gay
iconic movie i like it it's very gay
it's
it's a bette midler and uh i'm aware
it's gay kathy and jimmy
who is this little similarities
who's brilliant and uh sarah jessica
parker and it's a very gay funny
movie and i i enjoy that too it's not
really a horror movie
right uh favorite it's scary
here's why hocus pocus is legitimately
scary
everybody in the movie is white
that's terrifies me that they would have
such a lack of concern
for diverse was there one disabled
person
was there one person going through a
transition in the thumb
no thank you was there one black panther
in the movie no no
no good i like a movie called jacob's
ladder with uh tim robbins and
the guy yeah yeah phenomenal film and
danny aiello
great someone said and they were right
they were like danny aiello's face
is is on in every pizzeria in manhattan
if you've ever been in new york the
celebrity like pizzeria has put the
celebrities that have eaten there on the
wall
and danny aiello is in like more of them
than anyone else this is uh
oh my god does he look bad he looks oh
jesus is he still alive
i like danny aiello no he died in
december 12 2019.
sad he's great
well anyway yeah jacob's ladder yeah
great yeah
and it's about a guy that with the
vietnam and this is why i like it
because there's a little bit of a
backstory
it was about a guy that went to vietnam
and the government
experimented very similar to agent
orange they experimented with this drug
called the latter which made
uh american servicemen more vicious
and they in the movie they explain that
we were we were
not convinced that we could win vietnam
because our boys were soft
we needed them to be more vicious so we
needed to unlock
the real nightmares inside of them and
they
they all took their struggle the ladder
it's a cool movie and many of you may
enjoy it and then
i think at the end danny aiello's like
there's there's this great quote in it
that i like
danny aiello demons quote jacob's ladder
demons quote
demons and angels quote it's kind of a
fun little quote
demons are really angels yeah that's the
quote this is a fun movie by the way
many couples i see many couples come out
to the shows and
i like that i like that my fan base is
primarily heterosexual but at least many
of them are coupled up it's good to do
something every night
and not have one person that potentially
will like me ever
so i enjoy that it's nice you know
straight guys do comedy
people message them hey it was great you
wanna have a drink you know what i mean
people message me hey look at this pizza
menu
in omaha do you think the s is really uh
jacob this is a quote i like if you're
afraid of dying and you're holding on
you'll see devil's tearing your life
away but if you've made your peace then
the devils are really angels freeing you
from the world
it all depends on how you look at it but
danny aiello does the quote
so danielle's like if you made a piece
the devils are really angels
free from the world he's got garlic not
falling out of his mouth
it all depends on how you look at it
you see
i enjoy that film i like a lot of the
rob zombie movies devils rejects
which is a movie about comedians